تم تعليق الركاب لساعات، بعضهم لمدة
ثلاثة عندما توقفت رحلة الكرنفال هذه
على مساراتها في منتصف الحلقة في
ويسكونسن.
إنه مثل مفاوض الرهائن
التابع لشركة wjfw، حيث أفاد بأن ثمانية ركاب
كانوا محاصرين رأسًا على عقب في منطقة جذب كرة النار
في مهرجان مقاطعة فورست،
وهناك رجل عجوز في  في منتصف الحادثة
الأولى، أشار المسؤولون إلى وجود
عطل ميكانيكي في الرحلة ولكن
السبب الدقيق غير واضح، وهذا أمر مخيف فحسب، لقد
ظلوا هناك لمدة ساعة،
لذا فإن هذا الرجل
[موسيقى]
هذا الرجل هو شيء عالجته خدمة EMS للعديد من
المرضى في مكان الحادث و  تم
نقل أحدهم إلى مستشفى قريب
وفقًا للمسؤولين، قال مشغل الرحلة إن
السفينة الدوارة قد
تم فحصها مؤخرًا في الموقع من قبل ولاية
ويسكونسن
[تصفيق]
ها نحن ذا، أعتقد أن هذا ما سيفعلونه